you got it keep breathing eyes up chest
up my name's Randy Hetrick and I'm the
CEO and founder of TRX the TRX
Suspension Trainer is in an elastic
nylon harness for lack of a more elegant
way to describe it it allows you to use
your own body weight working against
gravity and integrating instability
across hundreds of common exercise
movements and it literally is a gym in a
bag it's a great way to training because
like many other functional training
approaches you are treating the body as
an integrated system rather than as this
broken down set of parts guarantee every
move that anyone's ever done in the gym
these straps will let you perform
anywhere before starting TRX I spent 14
years as a Navy SEAL it was an amazing
amazing place to start one's adult life
I deployed all over the world being a
seal was about the greatest thing that
I've ever done in my life
seals deploy into environments all
around the world where they go in
basically needing to maintain their
level of training like a pro athlete but
there are no gyms I came up with system
that truly was an invention of necessity
my invention was actually a fortunate
accident I had deployed on an operation
with my jujitsu blue belt
accidentally stuffed into my deployment
kit and thought what the hell I have
this thing here for but hmm maybe
there's something I can do here
I was the beginning of the TRX one of
the dirty little secrets is that you
know all seals at least all old seals
have to learn how to sew
modify your gears other than suit the
needs of seals sort of messing around
with my design and and just continue to
improve it dies to see me use it and
it's a can I go get a work out on it and
then it delivered I mean that's been the
thing about about that tool since the
day that I created it it always exceeds
expectations which ends up being really
important or the product I decided that
I would apply to business schools
Stanford and if I got in then that would
be sort of a natural pivot point to the
next chapter and to my everlasting
astonishment I was accepted but I wasn't
that compelled by some of the consulting
that was out there and I decided that I
would really kind of investigate the
feasibility of this as a business
because during the first year I would go
over and train they let me go in and
train at the athlete training center and
slowly but surely every single one of
the strength conditioning coaches that
would be there you know sort of saunter
over and see me working out on these
straps and come up and they had always
that same thing in this world-class
training room what are you doing with
these things and within five minutes
they'd be saying hey can I get on that
during the summer between my first and
second year I bought a sewing machine
sat down and started prototyping to
change this cro-magnon tool that I had
brought with me from the teams into
something that regular consumers might
buy I think a lot of people go to
business school and they don't know what
they want to do and I was certainly one
of those at the beginning but once I had
decided that this was the course on
which I was about to embark by the
Saturday I may as well make the second
year really relevant everything I did
was designed to answer questions around
a business plan or around the product
that I was in
to watch every single one of those
classes ended up teaching me things that
how I was gonna pursue this business
people didn't get it initially they
thought it was cool that I was this
little frog man and you know there was
no doubt that the thing would crush you
if that's what you were looking for
there was some question as to how many
of you know regular folks were
infinitely understanding the difference
of when to drive forward and when to
actually listen to some of the you know
the constructive feedback that you're
getting is is an art that successful
entrepreneurs figure out how to navigate
my mentor at the time thought it was the
craziest idea you ever heard of and he
did his level best to convince me not to
do this when you're starting a company
or any venture you know you've got to be
open to alternative perspectives that
may tell you hey this is a dumb idea but
I knew that at least among the elite set
of athletes and commandos it was
resonating so you know the question was
then alright how do we cross over on a
lark I decided to go to a trainer trade
show and took you know pretty much all
the all the money that I had left and
the first day there sold out everything
we had and that was one of those you
know sort of moments when you say hmm I
thought we were this but the markets
telling me we're actually this one of
the great ironies is it's become this
very popular tool among seniors for
senior wellness and fall prevention and
I never saw that one coming
entrepreneurship is not for the meek and
particularly bootstrap entrepreneurship
which by definition is you know the
undercapitalized which
startups are you gotta really rock up
and get ready to go into a protracted
extended battle from which there is no
retreat I really believe in the old
adage fall down ten times get up 11
because the path to greatness is paved
with the bones of those who did it you
need to make sure that you're one of
those cats that always gets up and keeps
going and if you do then then I think
you know it's a great lifestyle and it
affords all kinds of cool opportunities
that not many people get to enjoy
you